i have so i have been for a long time
i've kept a document that's like my
brain dump and if i come up with any
observation that i think is amusing i'll
just drop it in there and then when i'm
writing i can go look at that and it'll
spark oh yeah i remember that
observation that could work now um there
are there are professional comedians who
say that's a bad idea you shouldn't do
that because
if it's a really good idea you'll
remember it but
i i think even an idea that may not be
good right now could turn into something
good and you always want to be writing a
lot so i don't ever really throw
anything away it's rare i throw away an
idea but i have this main dump that i
put everything in and then every once in
a while i'll organize it especially if i
come up with something i think is
especially good
i'll organize it in a separate place
depending on what i think it's going to
be used for it's if it's a stand-up joke
it goes in that folder if it's a movie
idea it goes in that folder book idea
different folder etc cetera
and then so everything's organized by
project type
that generally helps me quite a bit
premises and jokes
i ca i just keep all my premises and
jokes bundled together
uh depending on what medium they're for
because i know when i sit down to
actually produce
something whether i'm writing stand-up
or
humor article or
let's say a script for something
i know there's not going to be like
notes that i'm going to be able to crib
verbatim i'm going to be basically
starting from scratch but i just want
you know what i want is i want someone
else in the room with me so what i who i
get is me from a few weeks ago when i
wrote down all these ideas
looking at something that's not just me
alone in my brain
so
that's that's how i do it that's how i
organize it and you know everybody's got
to have their own system that works for
them
but michelle you asked and that is how i
do it
uh hopefully that can help you figure
out what works for you
yeah and you know that was a big
takeaway from the comedy author series
we did is we tried to
we do all of them and then pick up on
common themes and one of the big themes
we found is it's like
here is a way to do it but it's like
what works for you may not work for
someone else or like
what p some people only may like be
um
like attracted to so like you have all
these funny filters for example but some
people may only have an intuition for a
few of them and that's how they hammer
out jokes you know it's just kind of
like
these aren't like in stone laws these
are like helpful guides but most of the
authors were like here's how i've seen
it work here's how i helped a lot of
people do it but it's also what works
for you and what's you're going to be
consistent with is what's going to help
you the most
exactly you know everybody's yeah
everybody's got to find their own way
okay i don't know where else oh i think
digital versus non-digital is where my
brain went to like it's whatever's most
intuitive for you but i will say as
someone who was non-digital
for all of my career and then the
pandemic hit and i started using google
docs
and like i now have one that is like
joke ideas i do have one that is like
new jokes i do have some that are sets
now when i go out to a show i'll still
have my set list that i write by hand
but
digital
if you can do it it's just more
searchable like if you're like oh i have
these that's what i looks like you can
search the topic and it's just right
there
that i would be dead without that search
ability and then with paper the reason i
mean i know i know a lot of people who
still just use a legal pad and they
swear by it
but i would lose that like if you lose
the paper you're done for like that's i
can't even imagine that that would be a
tragedy so gotta have it in the computer
gotta have it backed up and it's gotta
be searchable in my opinion yeah and she
asked if there's any apps i mean google
docs is free i've heard people use
evernote before
i i yeah i am mistrustful of anything in
the cloud or online and maybe that's
just because i'm old but i'm just scared
that it's going to disappear if it's not
on my computer so i always save a
document on my hard drive oh so it's all
on your actual computers how you yeah i
i'm i'm skeptical of the
i mean i'm sure i'm just being silly i
i'm sure it would work just fine and
also i would have access to it anyway
but then so
another thing i've been doing lately is
i'm doing voice notes so i'll just do a
voice note of something
and then the way apple makes those and
how you download them to your computer
is extremely inconvenient
so i need to figure out
a better way to manage that but i do
like that because sometimes i think
better when i talk as opposed to write
which i know a lot of comics uh have
that same
uh proclivity
yeah i mean what what was interesting to
hear
when we had mark normand on here was
like
he's a very meticulous writer so i was
like oh i bet he's very like
in the page and word for word but his
writing process is literally like
ranting and raving for an hour alone in
his room and then just picking things
that
found he found interesting or
potentially funny like it's a lot of him
just talking to himself like a crazy
person and then he'll like refine it
from there
yeah i have a lot of crazy person voice
memos myself